hey drew this is sergeant griswold  station of fort hill oklahoma hi drew i  am pfc caleb moore  i'm stationed at fort bliss texas i'd  like to give a shout out to my wife and  son  i love you guys and i can't wait to be  home i'd like to send a shout out to my  mom dalia  in houston texas hi mom i hope you're  having a great day i love you  hey drew this is sergeant matthew samlak  stationed out of fort sill oklahoma  hi drew my name is master sergeant  maddox  i'm stationed at fort hood texas hi drew  my name is specialist omar gomez  currently stationed overseas i'd love to  give a shout out to my mom i don't get  to see her very often  but i sorely miss her home cooking love  you mom  can't wait to see you soon because i  want to give a quick shout out to  my family back at home i love you guys  just want to give a shout out to my wife  jenny  my parents eric and sue my sister megan  i hope you guys have a great holidays i  miss you guys love you guys and i'll be  home soon  you